étranger
[Musique]
Je rassemble les plus grands
[Musique] de
tous les mondes
[Musique]
pour m'aider à faire la guerre,
dis-moi qui est vraiment cette guerre contre
moi
et ce que tu attends de nous
[Applaudissements]
essayant de ne pas mourir
plusieurs fois j'essaie de sauver  elle du
professeur
ça m'a coûté tout ce
qu'on pourrait être plus dangereux que toi
la vérité
[Musique]
quand je dormais mon frère je viens de me parler
je peux sentir la mort là-dedans
[Musique]
L'Autorité ils ont un pouvoir
bien plus grand que notre compréhension
quoi  si je ne peux pas planifier en arrière
[Musique]
nous vous trouverons
ils sont comme un bras de la Bête
hors de cela
[Musique]
et le reste va s'effondrer
Je fais demi-tour Je suppose que je reviens
[Applaudissements]
ceci  est une rébellion finale
[Musique]
eh bien je serai mort